hello playing a new five-minute game
against international master champ
Buster from Iceland champ ass Dan
probably played in before I always loved
those guys with its like big mouth names
blitz master Chen buster and so on
always nice all right so um what do we
have here juco piano Italian game yeah I
can play all kinds of fun normal looking
museum it's not much threatened here
should be six I can play at some point
probably next smooth you went to g3
sometimes you need to be a bit cautious
with cork a slingshot if Y them is able
to play a quick a 383 and reform okay so
we just retreated yeah I think black
should take the chance to to play d5
normally am in those openings if you
manage to play d5 it means you have
solved your opening the opening problems
really long castles
interesting okay I probably need a pawn
here anyway and this some maybe intends
to take on TV and play Bishop c4 he
doesn't seem to really hmm yeah well I
don't I don't as usual I don't
understand anything why is if i can now
can I take on any form nitey 4d takes e4
24 takes on d5 takes on d5 yeah maybe
queen bee three this line yeah i mean
it's it's it's it's not not particularly
good anyway what white is doing but then
maybe I could have taken only four I'm
not quite sure I prefer to play the Sun
bit more strategical trying to fight for
the default square it doesn't have
anything on the King side anyway quickly
at least I don't see it my idea now is
after taking on before just to put the
knight on d4 and I'm really quick with
opening up the Queen side I mean it is
opened up now already and he doesn't
even he doesn't even have a G porn or
something in motion okay so let's go
here and get this Bishop to a good
position
now it looks very nice for black as king
is really insecure yes so just down d7
our can I can play here attending 95
even as a sacrifice the night is a
really strong 97 so should I just just
sec the exchange now I don't know
you
it's probably not not bad 95 I'll take
care 95 Bishop takes e8 maybe be three
it's a good intermediate move my looks
very dangerous
I don't know maybe maybe this is some
not not entirely correct but it looks
really nice we should be aight i play b3
this was my idea
intending to take on a 4 B 3 as a
possibility I mean this is just just a
good attack here yeah answered quickly
so he's saying this is all all nonsense
basically yeah maybe it is I don't know
take here cool and then it takes on d 4
24 and Luke v8 isn't this dangerous that
looks dangerous
yeah it wasn't necessary to sacrifice
this exchange I only thought it would be
interesting now it is I mean I have some
compensation because it's a whole whole
whole formation here on the queenside is
just a wreck but it doesn't seem to to
win outright or something it's just
interesting get a night to see three now
yeah one problem is i don't i don't
actually have a look here on be eight
and i need it he doesn't threaten to
take because of 92 Jack came
so just the a porn shove the apron off
the board how can I can I can even grab
another like reason another look yeah it
wasn't probably a really correct from a
mathematical point of view this stuff
but it's attacking asking and not easy
to play yeah the computer thinks why
does winning this doesn't surprise me it
was necessary to do that I mean I said
before I just I just liked the idea here
in this position I can play em any kind
of move yeah the computer as usual own
is very simple-minded just wants to play
rook f8 now Brooke f8 and black has the
winning advantage getting out of the pin
threatening 95 and what exactly is white
playing a yeah this is actually very
strong if you look at this now he has no
way to to prevent night see file if he
goes here I've got rook be eight and
this is of course strong yeah in general
long castles just just bet him I mean
it's probably am I don't know it just
leads to a black advantage whatever he's
doing he simply doesn't have anything
going on the Kings side and I'm really
quick here with with with d5 defined so
on it's just an attack and he doesn't
have much counter play yeah thanks for
watching